>> Juan:
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST TWEETING
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE JAMES
MATTIS WILL BE RETIRING AT THE
HAND RELEASE THOUGH, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS?
>> Lisa: I FIND IT SAD.
I LOVE GENERAL MATTIS.
THIS IS A TOUGH GUY.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CRITICISMS.
I GUESS HE WASN'T REALLY
LISTENING TO HIS GENERALS
REGARDING SYRIA BUT ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CRITICISMS WAS THAT HE
WASN'T GOING TO FOLLOW THE
ADVICE OF HIS ADVISORS AND HE
WASN'T GOING TO SURROUND HIMSELF
WITH NECESSARILY THE BEST
PEOPLE.
IN CHOOSING GENERAL MATTIS, THAT
HELPED GIVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE
TO NAYSAYERS AND PEOPLE THAT
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE KIND OF
DECISIONS THIS PRESIDENT WOULD
MAKE.
I FIND IT DISAPPOINTING AND SAD
THAT GENERAL MATTIS IS LEAVING
PARTICULARLY AT A TIME WHEN WE
ARE DEALING WITH NORTH KOREA.
WE'VE GOT CHINA ON THE RISE AS
WELL.
>> Juan: JASON, THE THING IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP RECENTLY SAID
THAT MATTIS WAS LIKE A DEMOCRAT.
NOW YOU HAVE HIM, THE PRESIDENT
DEFYING MATTIS' SUGGESTIONS WITH
REGARD TO PULLING THE TROOPS OUT
OF SYRIA.
>> Jason: THE COUNTRY WILL OWE
A LOT TO GENERAL MATTIS.
FOUR DECADES OF SERVICE TO THE
COUNTRY IN THE MARINES.
IN AFGHANISTAN, IRAQ.
HE WILL BE REMEMBER FOR A LONG
AND STORIED CAREER.
IF THERE IS ONE GREAT PICK I
THINK THE PRESIDENT MADE EARLY
ON IN HIS CABINET IT WAS
GENERAL MATTIS.
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE, SO
MUCH RESPECT FOR THIS MAN AND
WHAT HE'S DONE.
ONE OF THE QUOTES I RECENTLY
READ FROM HIM, I WON'T GET THE
QUOTE EXACTLY RIGHT BUT HE WAS
BASICALLY SAYING ENGAGE YOUR
BRAIN BEFORE YOU ENGAGE YOUR
GUNS.
FOR A MILITARY LEADER TO THINK
LIKE THAT, TALK LIKE THAT, AND
TO BE ABLE TO BACK IT UP, IT'S
INSPIRATIONAL.
THERE'S A LOT TO LEARN FROM THIS
MAN AND WE'VE GOT TO THINK HIM
-- THANK HIM FOR HIS SERVICE.
>> Juan: GENERAL PERINO, WHAT
DO YOU THINK?
>> Dana: I AM NO GENERAL AT
ALL.
I CAN'T HOLD A CANDLE TO HIM.
GENERAL MATTIS WAS ABLE TO
FULFILL PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
DIRECTION WHEN HE ASKED FOR
TROOPS TO GO TO THE BORDER FOR
SUPPORT DOWN THERE.
HE DID THAT AND PUSHBACK ON
MEDIA CRITICISM OR SHOULD SAY
DEMOCRATIC CRITICISM.
HE WAS WILLING TO DO THAT AND HE
WENT TO THE MAT FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE IS GOING
TO HAVE ONCE AGAIN A BIG
NOMINATION FIGHT ON THEIR HANDS.
NOT A FIGHT, BUT IT WILL BE AN
ISSUE.
NOW THEY HAVE THE AG AT
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND DOD.
I WOULD SAY SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS.
IT'S BEEN RUMORED FOR A WHILE
AND THE DEMISE OF JIM MATTIS
HAVE BEEN RUMORED.
YOU COULD REPORTED EVERY WEEK,
SOMEBODY SAID HE WAS GOING TO BE
OUT THE DOOR.
BUT I WILL SAY IF YOU THINK BACK
TO THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
EVERYONE WHO WAS ON THE NATIONAL
SECURITY TEAM FOR
PRESIDENT OBAMA, ON THE LEFT AND
WROTE THEIR BOOKS, EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEM ALL SAID THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT LISTEN TO US
ON SYRIA.
HE DIDN'T LISTEN TO US.
HE DIDN'T TAKE OUR ADVICE.
BUT THEY STAYED.
OBVIOUSLY THIS CASE,